[Inaudible] appetite. He had appetite like Chris.
Just let me interject. What stopped in September 16,
20 small ship called the Mayflower left Plymouth,
England carrying 102 passengers at an assortment of religious separatists,
seeking a new home from where they could freely practice their faith in other
individuals, Lord, by promise of prosperity and land ownership in the new world.
Let me, let me just.
Add that, that, and it was a bad thing. Um, we wish.
It didn't happen back then. It was an infringement.
Encroachment on cultures and we're putting we're retroactively putting those
ships.
On. Yeah. I noticed the hole that hole. I know.
That section from your history book, remove it.
I know this. I love the unnoticed is the greatest thing. Let me just say,
when people talk about Thanksgiving,
it was like the way Americans have been taught that Thanksgiving,
that this just like these manifests that it's like my in my day they would
teach us no, it was evil.
The Puritans people acting like they teach you in school,
anything but negative stuff since 1965, they don't
take this imaginary world of the fifties has existed this whole time.
It has not in a few select school districts.
What you're basically saying is the Russians infiltrated our school system even
earlier.
Than we thought, duh. Exactly. Yeah.
They were teaching the anti-American propaganda way back. Yeah.
It's like, I love how people are this Thanksgiving. All right.
White people and Columbus, all that.
It's like the disease smallpox killed more people than anybody. Small,
positive white people was smallpox.
It was another thing the Chinese created in their lab.
In reality,
the people who are the most woke and mad are such few numbers.
They just have the loudest voices. But they really,
if you just don't do what they say and you just keep going, nothing changes,
nothing changes because they're small. It's a small.
Group. Yeah. Yeah. I think, I think actually people are realizing it and like,
it's like, it's people are gone. Like nobody cares. Nobody cares.
But you know what I got from reading your book really? Like,
it's a funny book obviously. Cause you wrote it. But what it.
Made me realize we really are not the United.
People of America. We are the United States of America.
Every state is kind of like its own thing.
But I didn't know that about Delaware, that it was so shady that corporations,
she gets, everyone sets up their corporation.
Because there's no tax. Oh, I lo and behold where's our president from,
I know Hillary lock a rock, but it is.
True. When you think about Delaware that he is from like Delaware,
that's just an agreement everybody's made that somebody's going to be their
corrupt state and they're like, we'll do it. you. Yeah.
It's like this hypocritical thing. And I met Chris Walken and I go, my family,
I know, you know, you probably heard this, but I was in LA in 1989. And I go,
I just want to tell you, you know, my family, you know, they,
we should go to your bakery. It's the best bakery. And he goes, yeah, I go,
your family's bakery is legendary. He goes, that was a long time ago.
So which state do you think.
From the book encapsulates America the most,
you mentioned Florida as a contender.
Yeah. I mean, Florida's our, you know, our shadow self, you know, I would say,
you know,
I mean Pennsylvania because it's got the Philly type cities and the
Pittsburgh type cities. So it's east coast and mid. Yeah.
And it's got like the urban it's like, it's like Trump.
And you know, I would say by, you know what I mean? It's just,
it's a compilation of everything,
basketball and football and all those little side cities, you know what I mean?
Everything like Scranton and then Eastern, like it's all the,
it's all the success at barely of America. And it also made.
The history. They still got Amish and Mennonites in there.
Original settlers, still a constant juncture in there. Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania should be a lot more interesting than, yeah.
Do you think of the founding fathers.
Yet came back and saw Philadelphia? They would go, we shouldn't have done this.
Jesus Christ. What happened here was Washington gets a battery to the wakeup.
Yes. Take them straight to an Eagles game and see, look,
look at what freedom gave
CRO or anti the electoral college. What's your opinion. Should we lose.
It, scrap it or should we continue to let Republicans win election? But.
People talk about the electoral college. I mean, you know, first of all,
is that like all the volts go, it's not like, you know,
Montana has the same amount of electoral votes. It's New York.
They're acting like this. I mean, it really wasn't a bit, by the way,
Connecticut is responsible for that. Anyway, I didn't take the fall, but I mean,
people liked it like that happened. Like as if they get the same,
that proportionally is probably pretty close.
So I don't know what the big conflict is with that because all ultimately it's
the representative democracy is a Republic, right? So it was not,
it was totally, if you want a total, I always say,
if you want a full democracy wheel, pure democracy is mob rule. That's what.
It is. And that's why they made it a Republic. Cause they were scared of them.
Yeah. And.
If you really wanted, if you didn't have, uh,
if you just lifted a popular vote, slavery would probably never have gotten it.
Wouldn't have got rid of slavery in 1865,
but these are the kinds of things that go on. I stole it from a friend of mine,
but he's not a comedian. So that's about it. No.
You don't, you don't have to credit them if it's that community. Yeah.
But I mean, but it's all, these are all good points. Like, so it's like,
there was a reason representative democracy exists,
even though it turns out to be distorted, like everything else, but it comes to.
The story. Right, right. Who's the person you always wanted to the most,
the person, the person you disagree with. Yeah.
I mean the best hand you I've ever got was a girl went to St. Savior's.
It was in prospect park on a rock and we had different philosophies and
religions that I enjoyed every of it. Yeah.
Full disclosure. My sister went to say savior.
She's older.
[inaudible].